il ne fallait pas être frileux pour
cette cinquième édition du marathon de
cerner la ville les coureurs ont fait
leur échauffement dans le gymnase durant
la course une moyenne de 5 degrés
celsius un vent assez fort
les conditions de ce marathon organisé
en hiver quand on organise une course en
été on espère avoir on pense avoir du
beau temps et on n'a pas toujours du
beau temps tandis que quand on organise
en hiver on s'attend pas à voir du beau
temps et on n'a pas du bouton le sportif
attend simplement de courir mais il
attend des challenges et le challenge
pour qu'on leur propose c'est de couvrir
tout de suite après les fêtes après les
buts de
du jour de l'an et de venir directement
aux bonnes résolutions de sportive avec
un départ rapide à travers les villages
de bullion et la celle les bordes
gaspard fombonne vainqueur des trois
dernières éditions creuse l'écart avec
ses deux poursuivants david webster et
didier subileau ont terminé dix minutes
derrière gaspard ils cavalent tout seul
tout seul avec un temps de 2 40 donc
c'est vraiment énorme là c'est un autre
niveau après pour gagner dix minutes je
vous faut vraiment être très fort moi je
pense que je manquais un peu de volume
sinon on voyait peut-être moyens de
descendre sous les feux et 2,40 mais de
la deûle à agneaux à inquiéter le
premier objectif de gaspard fombonne
pour cette édition amélioré le record de
l'an dernier en descendant sous les 2
heures 39 minutes
c'est chose faite il a parcouru les 42
km en deux heures 38 minutes sur les
derniers kilomètres on avait le vent en
pleine face on était très exposée donc
la fin de course était vraiment vraiment
difficile le début ça allait voilà je
m'égare d'une minute par rapport à l'an
dernier et d'une minute par rapport à
2015 donc voilà dans trente ans je peux
très peut-être le record du court avant
le record du monde de l'auvergnat déjà
donné rendez-vous à ses adversaires en
2019 pour tenter de battre cette
nouvelle performance